dash cam video shows a man finding
another way to use his head after
headbutting and flopping out of a car
window after leading deputies on a
high-speed chase the incident happened
on October 15th in Maran County Florida
according to authorities deputies
spotted a vehicle driving erratically
with speeds up to 100 mph they attempted
a traffic stop however the driver
refused the driver who was identif ifed
as Tyler Falcon solo can be seen driving
in between and later swerving in and out
of traffic
[Music]
Lanes then Deputy spot Falcon solo
heading toward the wrong side of the
road as an oncoming vehicle heads toward
the car it appears Falcon solo is about
to drive toward the median getting out
of the way but then does a complete
U-turn nearly avoiding a collision the
deputy gets closer to the vehicle as he
continu continues to drive in and out of
lanes nearing an intersection Falcon
solo then runs a red light picking up
his speed again the deputy attempts
another traffic stop but then Falcon
solo yet again begins to drive on the
opposite side of the
road authorities continue to follow him
as he keeps driving erratically the
chase goes on for some miles then falcon
solo turns towards a neighborhood
continuing to Swerve in and out of lanes
as he attempts to evade police Falcon
solo nearly hits another oncoming
vehicle
gre
gre then moments later narly hits
another vehicle which authorities say
was parked by a nearby Trail Falcon solo
flees again but the deputy is able to
catch up with him as he heads into
another
neighborhood
left turn on
for turn right on man
pass right on moments later Falcon solo
is seen turning and crashing into a
mailbox before getting away the deputy
finds him and begins to inch closer
towards his vehicle coming up to
30 try
to
3 set up S
10 40 cross street authorities deploy a
stop stick to flatten all four of the
tires later Falcon solo heads towards a
resident's fence before crashing right
through it Third Street
pull after crashing he thinks quick on
his feet or in this case his head and
headbutts through the car window after
using the force of his own head Falcon
solo then hops over the fence and takes
the chase on foot through the depuy's
body cam video you can see the
shortlived chase between the deputy and
suspect authorities spot Falcon solo who
is caught and then bitten by the depuy's
Kine St here here F the man buddy get on
the ground now he's telling me please
I'm yeah hold on deputies are able to
cuff him as he then tries to give
authorities an explanation of what
happened I was at the gas station and I
had my chain on somebody tried to B me
all right please the Maran County
Sheriff's Office says 24 4-year-old
Tyler Falcon solo was arrested and taken
to a nearby hospital where deputies say
he stated he was high on drugs Falcon
solo was charged with DUI aggravated
fleeing and resisting arrest without
violence jail record show Tyler Falcon
solo is still behind bars being held on
a more than $50,000 Bond his next
scheduled court appearance is slated for
November 14th reporting for long crime
Network I'm Elizabeth Milner